one thing I've never understood about
concerts is like what is the point of
encour what I guess I think it was
probably a cool thing at once and now
it's just expected so I think like it's
lost its job yeah as as as now that it's
expected that you put like your coolest
song in The Encore then I'm like well we
all know it's coming we all know you're
going off stage here although I will say
I recently went to a concert of um this
like American Musician Mike canella who
I really really like and he had his like
new band that he was touring with in
Japan and I got tickets to go see it cuz
[__] love my canell and uh they've
only ever released one album right so
it's like very new band but I'm like
cool I'll go watch them they basically
did all of their you know songs that
they've released up until that point and
they started walking off naturally
everyone was like onore oncore Mike
comes back and he just goes on the mic
and he's like we don't have any songs
left and then he just leaves I'm just
like you know what I respect that it's
like it's like Uno reverse card on The
Encore it's like you know that's that's
refreshing feel like it's why do people
[__] saber a champagne why do they it
was just tradition right people just do
it cuz we just did it have you ever sa I
I want to I Sab champagne I want to
saber champagne sa champag did you do it
right uh no okay wellit what did you use
you can ruin the
whole actual
sa yeah yeah yeah are used like a proper
saber that was like this big I did it
with Chad when I was in Melbourne of
course it was with Chad okay now now now
that makes sense and and I did it and
but it it was like the I guess not the
correct way to do it cuz like the
correcte no no no it was it was the
proper way is that you know the cork is
supposed to like perfectly fly off and
you know the the the glass supposed to
just perfectly snap off yeah oh then I
did do all right it was perfectly flat
it was like kind of like at an angle so
like okay clean cut is what we're clean
C the risk is that the like glass shards
can go in the champagne as well as just
smashing the entire bottle but you just
[__] you just well I mean it's I mean
it's a lot harder than that but
generally yeah yeah I mean yeah
you sabered a champagne bottle I I I
could believe that much of an
achievement that's just such a [__]
rare thing to do really yeah it's like
fencing do you know anyone who fences no
yeah right I don't know a single person
who's fenced but you can say that about
like most Olympic sports okay okay never
SP huh equestrian I don't know if
someone's equestrian [__] off you do I
don't know anyone who's fenced who do
you know who's an equestrian I mean I
lived around farms and [__] so people
did that [__] what on sheep on on horses
just get on your r just fing drum the
fence I don't know s I'm I'm convinced
fencing is a
lie I not about a single person who's
fenced what what what do you mean I
think it's a conspiracy what it's a
conspiracy created by the Olympic
Committee I don't think it exists right
I think they just they they they just
find five dudes who are willing to do it
and they tell us it's a real thing okay
fencing's real let's keep it exciting I
think we should take the armor off and
fencing take the armor off and just go
back to old school just just let them
Slaughter each other why why do why does
they need like the little the original
Greek uh sry the original Olympics Way
Way Back had a fight to the death so
that was we should have that yeah we
should bring that back yeah bring that
back do you think Esports should be in
Olympics no no I like we went from me
joking about fencing not being
real no they did about the real they did
try this and it failed Miss yeah it did
fail I believe soorts yes uh Olympic
eort like last year I remember it was a
funny thing in Japan yeah no not in
Japan in general just in general oh like
the Winter
Olympics wait what well cuz last year
was the Winter Olympics right no no no
like the like I think the previous
Olympics that happened oh like I yeah
there's something something could you
look this up K yeah something happened
last year where they did something and
it was it was a mess they [__] it all
up what were they playing I don't know
this is the problem with gaming right is
that there's only a few games that have
stuck around long enough to really be
like I guess have that Olympic feel to
them of like a a thing we all know I
just can't imagine being like all right
so here's the swimming and here's the
gymnastics and then there's Quake
there's no games that feel Olympic you
know what I mean that's that's that's my
Mario Tennis get the [__] out
Joey player right after the tennis well
I mean they did um the only people who I
think of the biggest example I can think
of similar was OverWatch did their their
Global OverWatch competition where it
was country based yeah and it was it was
you know it was it was different from
the league it was just purely a like
whose country is the best well no
because uh league is in the Asia games
uh which is kind of like kind of like
the Olympics but just for like the Asian
countries and that's split up by
countries as well well you know Faker
doesn't have to enroll for the military
anymore yeah saw that yeah yeah it's
because he won a gold medal at the Asia
games I love how I love how BTS couldn't
get an Redemption from serving in the
military but Faker could I'm I'm trying
I'm not trying to say that Faker hasn't
contributed more to so I'm just saying
like BTS couldn't get it yeah and it's
cuz Faker he he won like they like the
Korean team won the gold medal for the
Asia games uh all they had to do is
basically beat China and they were
basically uh Shire to win uh and because
of that yeah can't wa for League of
Legends finals this year I'm so so
stoked so okay going back on Toby though
cuz who gives a [__] uh what is what
sport or what game would be the most
suitable for an Olympics situation Super
Smash
BR well no CU like America would just
win this is the problem with a lot of
Esports is that like America just
crushes in so many of them except for
certain games yeah uh like fighting
games is like dominated by mainly
Americans but there are some Europeans
obviously who have like like lean or
whatever or there's some Japanese people
who are pretty good them matero in
certain games but a lot of games are
dominated by just America what about Wii
Sports no jo no why not it's got [__]
Sports in the name bro Nintendo Nintendo
would ruin stuff somehow it'd be like
we'd be like oh we're doing guys we're
doing Smash Bros for to save dying kids
in terms like we've already put them
down stop stop it shut down we whack
them over our head with a copy of Smash
Bros it's just like the would find a way
cuz someone owns it right why would we
want to play watch Wii Sports in the
Olympics when we have all of the sports
that are in Wii Sports actually
represented you can just say that about
Esports in general then oh I'm sorry
Joey where in name me a real life
equivalent to League of Legends yeah
it's true there shouldn't be one that's
the point that shouldn't Counter Strike
other than terrorism which isn't rank we
don't have rank Terror we don't want to
talk about Counter
Strike well it's cter two now see try
too you know okay yeah we that's that's
what we don't want a real life
equivalent of
uh but yeah I mean wi Sports okay here's
is is
like should like things like bowling and
darts be part of the Olympics yeah I
think so yeah are they already they're
not right I don't no no they have their
own like like championships America will
win bowling though and do no no no no or
some European country oh really I have
no idea unless they can't drink while
performing in which case uh the UK just
gets nerfed to nerfed to the ground so
you cannot take performance enhancing
drugs and the British are like [__] I
sure a tweet that was um it was like
let's do like an Olympic games but where
everyone is allowed to take as many
drugs as they want like let's let's get
the the the best performing human with
everything that we can give them just
absolutely max out all stats are you not
curious what how fast a man could run if
he has full access to
drugs
if they're going to do it let's just
let's just make a league for
it what is like a speedrun strat like
yeah you can you imagine how fast Usain
Bolt will be when he takes [__]
cocaine we have like glitchless we have
Glitch that's not the kind of drugs that
improve running I'm pretty sure we have
like glitchless categories in games why
don't we have like drug categories and
and clean
categories that's a great idea what what
would we be promoting here corner what
what would we be promoting that drugs
in all these vape and smoking companies
would love sight to sponsor I'm
sure I I'd argue make more money more
readership is it legal to take weed
before like professional eaters go into
like an eating
contest that's a fantastic idea um if
they're not doing that they should does
that count as a performance enhancing
drug at that point because you're on the
munies bro and you're like I can eat 1.5
times the average right now are so good
yeah they should if if if there isn't
like an American like if Matt Stony
isn't doing that then I'm impressed he's
called Matt Stony so maybe
there's
maybe it's in the name yeah it's right
in the name we've figured out your trick
mat